bonsoir la décision prise hier par le
parlement algérien de supprimer le
français dans le pays provoque de
sérieux remous tente alger qu'à paris
cette décision législative a pour
objectif d'imposer progressivement la
langue arabe d'ici 1992 dans tous les
secteurs de la vie publique sur place
l'opposition crie au scandale à la
répression voire au caractère fascisant
des législateurs cinq cent mille
personnes ont manifesté cet après midi à
alger contre l'intolérance et
l'arabisation au rabais morad aït
habbouche les youyous d'une femme kabyle
les slogans reprises en arabe et en
français plus de 500 mille personnes
étaient présentes cet après midi dans
les rues d'alger pour dire non à
l'intolérance non à la loi sur
l'arabisation hocine aït ahmed le
président du front des forces
socialistes ici porté en triomphe
n'hésitent pas à braver la nouvelle
législation il choisi le français pour
expliquer son point de vue pour la
langue à langue arabe moderne
performante rationnelle nous sommes donc
mais dirk nous voulons également que les
langues étrangères et pourquoi pas le
français continue à être enseigné
pendant universités dans les universités
précisément l'arabisation a déjà
commencé depuis le début des années 70
avec l'ancien président boumédiène
l'enseignement primaire et secondaire a
subi le même sort
en fait seule la haute administration du
secteur économique avait été épargné
depuis hier c'est fini les documents
officiels doivent être rédigés en arabe
sous peine de sanctions sévères
les amendes allant de 500 à 50 mille
francs toute la société algérienne et
concernés y compris le secteur culturel
est filmé par exemple devons être
présenté en arabe
mais qui est vraiment le père de cette
nouvelle loi sûrement le fils le front
islamique du salut
depuis leur victoire aux élections
municipales les islamistes n'ont cessé
de faire pression auprès du gouvernement
et du parlement
hier ils ont remporté une autre victoire
attention toutefois
abassi madani le leader du fils n'a plus
le droit lui aussi ne s'exprimer en
français
c'est une victoire du peuple algérien
son journal non plus un seul faux pas
peut lui coûter 50 mille francs
reste qu'aujourd'hui dans les rues
d'alger l'opposition démocratique s'est
manifesté ils ont aussi fait entendre
leur voix
parce que l'étoile on croira cabine
forme identique en attendant tant
l'espagnol
oui ça tout est ok c'est dire en anglais
ma bouche on lui demande s avérer 4